one of our editors were looking at a
short video that they were like man I
really thought this was a good video and
it totally tanked it got like 4,000
views which for us was a tank they
looked at it made some notes and all
they did was they chopped the first 5
Seconds basically just readed the first
5 Seconds of the video and that one
change took it from 4,000 views to
850,000 views with that one change
that's a 200x increase from one change
which is how people framed the value
that they were about to consume if the
first 5 seconds is what immediately
sorts 80 90% of the traffic that you
have then isn't it crazy that we don't
spend more time testing that one piece
is